hey everybody it's Friday that means
it's time for another movie review yeah
we got to go in today this one is
Westworld right 1973 yes the original so
you know we did new sci-fi last week so
this week we're gonna do some old sci-fi
because the 70s is pretty much our
favorite decade for at least for horror
and sci-fi type movies yeah it was a
weird time not a lot had been done yeah
and a lot of the really big names were
just starting to come up at this time
you know this is Michael Crichton and he
ended up doing actually Jurassic Park
yeah among many men wanted many other
things and if you ask me you don't even
see it one that would came out new
course of 73 I was only maybe four years
old but when you when I first watched
this movie this week towards the end
with your old Brenner this is the
inspiration for the Terminator okay
definitely definitely is there is so
much in this that is reflected in the
Terminator in it and I didn't realize
that I I probably haven't seen this
movie since I was a teenager and then we
recently saw it again because we got the
blu-ray and the more I watch them like
oh yeah yes is definitely the Terminator
yeah when you watched Westworld
once you take your favorite parts of
this movie and condense it down that's
pretty much what you got in terminator
terminated with just more of that yeah
it was just a different setting it was
kind of like taking the second half of
West world and just like putting it in
the modern-day city is yeah Old West or
whatever all the last year but it was a
very similar kind of premise yeah okay
so what's the background in this no okay
so this movie was actually written and
directed by Michael Crichton who
obviously like I said you know Jurassic
Park is probably the most famous but he
wrote a million other books disclosure
and all this other stuff now in 1973 he
had written several well-received novels
he actually started out as a medical
doctor which most people know and he had
made he had written the Andromeda Strain
and a few other books now this was the
first movie that he directed yeah now
you mentioned a dramatist rain we're
gonna get back to a dramatist rain
because that was a good movie yes
requested that like yeah and that's been
on this list for a long time yeah
because this is one
that's a really good yeah and there's
another one kind of related to this
we're gonna go ahead and tease that one
we're gonna do demon seed yeah we
definitely have to even see is even more
so an inspiration in a certain way to
terminator
yeah if you were to take demon seed and
West world and kind of mash them
together that would be Skynet and
Terminator yeah basically you can see
where James Cameron got that did you see
where they guys yes okay so Michael
Crichton this was like I said he was a
successful novelist this was the first
movie that he that he was allowed to
direct MGM gave him a little over a
million dollars you know he wasn't a
proven director so they said well here
try this out you have to do sci-fi he
said I didn't really want to do sci-fi
when I started out but yeah that's
apparently what everybody thinks I'm
good at so they gave me money to do that
now he had been asked why he didn't
write Westworld as a book but he said
well the reason was that when I thought
about it he said because the theme parks
that make up the you know the bulk of
the story he's like because they were
based so much on old Hollywood and old
TV cliches about those particular
historical periods he's like so I felt
that it had to be a visual Rory
like me he's like I didn't really think
it would work on the page so he decided
to do it as a movie as I said MGM
directed this and MGM at that time they
were kind if they kind of had a bad
reputation among filmmakers for you know
excessive meddling in the script and the
casting and things like that
Michael Crichton was assured that he
wouldn't have these problems yeah he did
have some of these problems with you
know MGM kind of messing with the script
and saying put this in take this out and
also I don't think the casting was
actually finalized until two days before
they started shooting broadcast talking
about cast in this movie they cast one
of my all-time for a favorites that was
Yul Brenner Yul Brynner was rad yo
Brenner was actually like the original
Terminator which is kind of surprising
because he's kind of sawed-off little
[ __ ] actually you know he's not I
probably about my size maybe eight five
six five seven yeah but there's
something about your Brenner with his
face and the way he moves he's a
powerful little dick yeah he hasn't fit
yeah he has a very
intimidating-looking faceless expression
he's kind of almost kind of like like
something from like Siberian look to him
almost like nice like the Oriental it
looks really cool bald head and plus he
has he has very fluid graceful movements
he's very cat-like yeah look at man
which I think really kind of helped him
in this role now I've read that Michael
Crichton actually wrote the role of the
gunslinger with Yul Brynner in mind
because he wanted him to he wanted to
base the character around Yul Brynner's
character from The Magnificent Seven
yeah
so if you see him in the magnums he
looks exactly the same as whoever the
Magnificent said the same outfit and
everything
so that's kind of the thing he was going
for like I said so the whole premise of
the movie and we're kind of gonna get
into this a little bit cuz yeah what I
was watching this you know we were kind
of like we were laughing at oh yeah like
I love the movie but if you can't think
about it too hard no you can't think
about the primacy right okay one thing I
do really like about this movie is they
don't really have too much exposition
nobody's not a character development not
even sure who's what their names are yes
like I think they're only named one time
right like the two main guys are pretty
much the only characters that are named
except maybe a couple of the robots
right and their names are John and Peter
they're played by James Brolin from
Amityville Horror
yeah but he's beardless in this yeah and
also Richard Benjamin yeah there's an
amusement park they're gonna go they're
paying $1,000 a day and that's in 1973
money yeah and I I checked that is
almost equivalent to six thousand
dollars a day in today's money yes these
are ultra rich so yeah these are these
are rich as people yeah so they're
paying $1,000 a day to go to this theme
park it's called the whole theme park is
called Delos yellows gym but they
actually have three worlds now Michael
Crichton has said that he got this idea
about the androids everything like that
from Disneyland Disney World the Hall of
Presidents he's like right Androids they
had so he's like wouldn't it be cool if
there was a whole park like that except
taken to the enth degree yeah there were
three different sections right a wild
west section yeah ancient Roman section
and a medieval section and you can
choose whichever one you wanted to go to
it of course each one kind of offered
its own thing you know
yeah the Rome of course was all just
about wild sex and partying we'll see
you to me it seems like Roman world
which was actually I didn't I don't know
if they mentioned this I think they
mentioned it once in the movie but it
was supposed to be Pompeii oh yeah
hopefully without that bulb out
bazoombas thing to remember is if the
movie came out 73 and this is supposed
to be predicting the very distant future
of 1983 yeah I don't know if they
mentioned that the movie either but not
a Wikipedia page it says this is
supposed to be taking place in 1983 and
I'm like that's adorable that they
thought they thought they could never
have androids that were like
indistinguishable from humans in just 10
short years and this badass hovercraft
that takes them take something yeah they
don't share the hovercraft yeah it looks
kind of like a little Martian flying
machines from that old war of the
worlds' into the Martian yeah this what
it look like to me
okay so basically they have these three
parks and they are supposed to be
completely immersive yeah we're supposed
to go into your chosen world and there's
all these androids that look
indistinguishable from people except for
their hands are not quite right that is
the only thing that makes
distinguishes them which is kind of
weird they could duplicate the human
mind but they couldn't do the hand of
course yeah that was yeah that was one
of the things they're like oh they can't
get the ants just right or whatever so
like I said it supposed to be two
totally immersive so you can go you can
get in sword fights in medieval worlds
you can have orgies and Roman world and
it's just and it's fine because it's
androids and yeah that's what their job
is
yeah and they can't hurt you that there
they programs so they Susilo say yeah
and well that's kind of the funny thing
though the movie starts out with like a
fake commercial for the same part where
people are coming from the little Delos
thing they're the guys interviewing them
where did you go
you know medieval Europe yes I
a sword fighter I was the king or I
bangs the Queen or whatever idea I
especially I especially like the one she
was like a kind of older lady and there
so she was in Roman world she's like
yeah that wasn't really the main problem
with this movie when I was watching I
recommend the movie it's a good movie to
watch if you want to see where things
came from like once where the Terminator
came from yeah but the problem if you
asked me with the movie is that about
the first one-third of the movie is
useless exposition because the audience
of 1973's has to be explained what an
Android is and you have to be explained
what what what a service like that would
offer you nowadays we hear about worlds
filled with androids and we instantly
know what yeah you know what that is so
you don't need to explain to you wait a
minute don't you need don't mean robot
robot yes robot on several I'm not sure
okay so at some point because it seems
to me that every sci-fi movie from like
the early to mid 70s
they said robits robits their robot but
something after the late 70s or early
eighties then people started saying
robot so I was like everybody just kind
of decided that they were gonna
pronounce it correctly said robot
started to sound too too lame I guess
robot may have been a California thing
robot robit' so so the thing is so they
do the commercial and when the two guys
John and Peter are going to the park now
John who's played by James Brolin
he has been there before yeah he's like
on a second diamond yeah and he went to
West row before now his little nebbishy
friend played by Peter bent or Richard
Benjamin with the pornstache with the
pornstache he had never been before so
that's where a lot of he's also dashing
he's all stashed no no arms or anything
but a guy would just stand all of his
muscles hurt story is my stash yeah this
is a powerful biceps that will punch you
kind of like Chuck Norris this one yeah
yeah so yeah so he's very dweeby and
he's like doesn't really know how
he's never been before so that's kind of
how a lot of the exposition happens
we're with James Brolin telling his
friend like oh it's do you do this and
they actually have sex with these robots
so you can this is my first time yeah
but yeah but I mean I think that's kind
of the whole point of it is that you
know supposed to be that he's supposed
to be graduate yeah yeah so he's kind of
like the audience surrogate actually
most of the guys pan to go to this world
or cringy well it's like ranbir wait
middle-age that was actually the most
realistic part of it I thought because
here's the thing Westworld the whole
premise the whole reason why you would
choose to go to West world perfect this
is a vacation yeah paying $1,000 for
them yeah is to is because you want to
get in gunfire one of the event is you
know getting bar brawls yeah and bang
saloon check yeah right so you're
spending your whole vacation to get your
ass beat pretty much beat other people
say can't really resist really they
could just pretend to resist because
they're programmed to let usually a win
or to let you do whatever like if you
hit on the girls their program so might
be oh you're the most wonderful yeah it
would suck yeah I just so to me and
since West world is supposed to be like
immersive you know there's no running
water there's no you know it's just
1800s yeah it's a western town yeah in
the desert so I just don't see that
being any fun yeah which means Roman
world would have would have like
vomitorium sand things like actually I
think they went ahead and said that for
the most part the set that the sections
of this theme park are based upon novels
yeah period not the reality yeah they're
based all they're based around an
idealized yeah I need obviously so
you're not going to like medieval world
and getting people on a plane right I'm
not having toilet I think what's really
cool about the movies that once once it
starts rolling you find out that the
technicians who built this world are
having a problem with something they
describe as a disease yeah that jumps
from one robot to the next and affecting
their behavior which is probably one of
the first concepts of computer virus
yeah
is actually they don't use the word I
work computer but the way they describe
it is their computer fighters talk and
as far as I know this is the first film
reference to a computer virus yeah now
one of the gunslingers in West world one
of the models there that keeps getting
shot up and keeps getting its ass
whipped by the nemesis that they visited
is that is that is the gunslinger that
is played by your Brenner
somehow or another this robot gets
destroyed a couple times that's upgraded
each time and it picks up this computer
virus along with all the other robots
and in the in all three yeah whatever
looks like was last one that's affected
right and this robot seems to become
semi-sentient yeah and goes on a mission
of revenge
to try to hunt down the guys that have
shot him a couple of times and that's
really when this program if you ask me
gets interesting because it becomes the
inspiration for terminator right guys
running from basically an indestructible
little mechanical man yeah it's a badass
with guns and you really can't hurt him
yeah beat him to death
they threw acid on him they threw fire
on and many he doesn't respond to it in
the same way a human would and that's
really the premise of the movie yeah
it's the prototype for the Terminator
yeah more or less
yeah now here okay so here's the thing
now the problems of the movie like I
said I really like this movie and it's
really enjoyable and you can see how oh
and I also forgot to mention too not
only is this the first mention of the
concept of a computer virus this is also
the first movie to use technically CGI
yeah and they only used it with yul
brenner when you're seeing through his
eyes everything looks pixelated yeah and
infrared and so that we should that gets
lifted out of the Terminator when you
see through the terminators eyes and
infrared and you know and you see little
the computer pointing things out
highlighting machines yeah actually
you'll Brenner's robot his character is
kind of doing that too so yes isolated
and they set in video and he can also
see infrared footprints
remember that crisis like heat
signatures just like a horse's right
because they upgrade the upgraded his
vision
his hearing cuz he kept getting shot up
too much mellower yeah the new infrared
units because that was his whole his
whole thing Yul Brynner's gunslinger
character he was supposed to be the guy
that instigated gunfight yet a little
bit the guests wanted to get into so he
would go in a bar and start giving you
[ __ ] yeah Napoleonic gunfighter yeah and
then like the guests would be like oh
yeah I'm gonna blow your freakin it I
think they get to shoot him and blur I
got to kill a man except not really
right so yeah so that was like his whole
deal now yeah and yo looks badass he's
all in black he's got that little face
of his with that bald head and those
eyes and in this movie his eyes glaze
out turned white
yeah sometimes when that virus yeah
that's a shiny all right and you kind of
like when he's becoming semi-sentient
you can say anything there other than a
draw or y'all know we says all this
stuff to memories is you like a baby
[Music]
gunfights now yeah has it been a Russian
accent in that in that cowboy outfit
which actually is pretty accurate
eighteen hundreds of fill with European
immigrants yeah if you were a badass in
your hometown you could come to America
becoming even a battery with those coal
45 batter a batter ass okay so here's
the thing though and here's where even
though I really like this movie here's
where you have to suspend your disbelief
somewhat yeah because one like I said
1973 it's kind of hard to believed in a
1983 you're gonna have androids that are
indistinguishable from human yeah and
the more that the exposition the people
that run the park are saying like
nothing can possibly go wrong nothing
can possibly hurt you right you're just
like I you know what even if you didn't
know that this was like a sci-fi horror
movie obviously that cannot be the case
yeah and they also had the guns rigs to
where none of the guns could actually
shoot a human being that can only shoot
robots right because okay supposedly
because they have punch each other yeah
and all kinds of weird things throwing
chairs on each other how could you not
get hurt
see that doesn't
that's the problem I had because now
before they did that said the thing
about the guns because they did address
that because I was like well wait a
minute how because you can't distinguish
the other guests from robots right it's
like well what if you shoot a real
person well yeah I'm just gonna push it
up or whatever but then so then James
Brolin explains to his buddy
he's like oh well no the guns have
sensors in them that will only let you
shoot something that's not warm-blooded
or like you know below a certain
temperature right I'm like ok but the
swords in medieval world don't have that
your fist drive that is thrown from
horses and robot horses yeah they had
robot horses and robot rattlesnakes yeah
and the thing is that during one big
climactic scene the two guests are they
have a big fun bar brawl yeah and
they're getting thrown through windows
they're having chairs thrown at them and
they're getting punched and stuff like
that like you're gonna get hurt right
and there could be accidents even before
the robots yeah go apeshit yeah you know
or whatever happens at the virus it's
like it just seems really easy for
something to go wrong
yeah and I mean what if you shot at the
gun slinger today and it's a ricocheted
and it hits you in the face
yeah it's somebody else that's what I
mean it just seems like it was employee
legal ramifications of this theme park
if it really existed would just be it
wouldn't be worth it although one of the
guys in the control room said well there
is some danger that's the appeal of it
so maybe I was 1973 sensibilities in
terms were maybe you signed a waiver at
the end of it with you know the one guy
that was left and everything he's just
sitting there like you know looking like
oh man had this all happen I'm like and
he's a lawyer that's one of the only
things you know yeah he's a learned I'm
like he is gonna sue the [ __ ] out of
everybody when he gets
oh yeah the movies worth seeing we
priced shouldn't spoil everything about
it about how it goes down cuz really all
the interesting stuff is in like the
last half of the movie but when you have
your old Brenner just chasing ya because
really just a relentless kind of yeah
it's chase like para movie got very
reminiscent of the Terminator I think
also that you'll burners character was
also a little bit the inspiration for
Michael Myers probably yeah
it's like it this kind of emotionless
yeah thing that was just coming after
you and couldn't stop and you really the
story I can see that I've heard that too
yeah
but Terminator definitely yeah but you
know the thing about it like I said
that's the boring parts out of out of
West world put a motorcycle chase and
have a 18-wheeler blow up a little bit
of stop-motion okay and then that puppet
that the guy was wearing on his back
yeah that would be Terminator you have
all that you have all the necessary
elements to make a Terminator movie but
it would have been in 1973 yeah they
should have slightly rethought it
because it would have been a really good
action movie yeah yeah I mean it seems
more like it doesn't really get into
like the action of the chase or anything
so last part of it because they spend
really the first two thirds of the movie
setting up how that works
yeah and following other character like
other guests at the Parkland like dick
Van Patten is in the run and he's kind
of like this fat pudgy guy reason old
with he wants to be the sheriff and I
have a feeling that the set up actually
and even in 1973 was considered to be
kind of dull had they retold this story
slightly and gotten rid of all that had
more more chase scenes and more action
with you old runner I think it would
have done a lot better even though this
movie was not a failure it made ten
times its invest it was very six in fact
it was so successful that they made a
sequel in 1976 called future world which
I haven't seen although I've heard it's
terrible yeah they also made a TV series
yeah five episodes in 1980 called Beyond
West world now I am not only five
episodes were made and only three aired
because the ratings were abysmal well
that our DV or our blu-ray King with the
pilot pilot episode and I can see why
yeah not good I can see why nobody
wanted to watch that it wasn't poorly
made it was poorly conceived what they
were trying to do would not have been
interesting well it didn't have much to
do with the original concept no other
than a
droids it had androids in it but it
didn't really have much to do with the
theme park idea which is what I think
everybody liked about the movie it was
just androids trying to take over the
world yeah like they're trying to take
away nuclear submarines that would have
been like the genesis of Battlestar
Galactica yeah it was just like that
well like I said I went out all the cool
shiny Cylons right so a Star Wars like I
said the whole thing about the other
thing about Westworld the original movie
was the theme park right lady and her
maid west world yeah to that Runner was
in the sequel thesis world like I said
but he was the only returning cast
member but like I say the first one yeah
well like I said I haven't seen it but
I've seen maybe one person review it
that said they liked it better than the
original but then everyone else is like
yeah it's awful right and I will also
admit obviously that HBO has made a West
World Series mostly really what season
has aired the seventh season is going to
air I admit I have not seen that either
but I've heard very good things about it
so eventually I would like that because
I do like that concept because I like
the concept of Epcot and Disney world
whether it's like this immersive world
that you wouldn't normally get to
experience but like I said there's some
things about West world that probably
need to get tweaked some to make it more
believable especially this day and age
because to me like we were saying
obviously Roman world is the only one
worth going to because at least they
have swimming pools and feasts and
orgies and wine is pretty comfortable
and comfortable togas yeah you know if
you go to medieval world you got to wear
all those hot clothes armor their armor
there's like sword fighting yeah yeah
it's like that just doesn't sound like
much fun it sounds like work yeah so I'm
sitting there going well where okay so
where is the center and I'm ass eating
cupcakes without gaining weight world
that's the world I want a vacation in I
don't want to go back and live in some
bad historical Iberian I think that
pretty much wraps wraps it up with this
though I mean I would probably put it
not quite on par with demon seed demon
seed is a lot better demon seed is very
underrated to Marionnaud rated but I
would recommend the movie just to see it
for kind of historical purposes like
this is where the Terminator came from
yes because it was I think it was very
influential yeah if you're a terminator
fan terminator one fan you should
probably see and Yul Brynner is
definitely the highlight of this movie
but like I said just kind of turn your
brain off and don't think about it too
much right and you know especially that
one part where you know where that were
the control room they have to shut
everything down sell the robots are
going am i running amok and they're just
like oh well now we're shutting the room
we can't breathe right like you think
they would have worked out a fit we can
make androids that are just like humans
but we did make a fail-safe um doesn't
like shut us it's just weird does demon
seat was around this time and it was
just so much more realistic and actually
so much more frightening yeah
demon seat was weird yeah we're we got
to do a show on that we definitely well
so yeah demon seed we gotta do we're
gonna do Andromeda Strain would you yeah
they're Michael crow yeah that's right I
haven't seen that mages he did coma as
well right and the dramatist a drama
strain is better than Westworld I think
yeah yeah yeah I haven't seen it in a
long time but I do remember liking that
a great deal yeah so hopefully you
enjoyed this look back at West world
from 1973 kind of a cool influential
little sci-fi and especially if you like
the you know the HBO series yeah last
year there before you made brassy it
yeah then you should probably go back
and check out the origins yeah that
Terminator 1 if you like that then you
brought like this yeah because you can
really see the timeline that the
employee where they've got a lot of that
yeah so that'll do it for this Friday
movie review and if you would like to
support the show please remember to go
to our patreon page at patreon.com slash
13 o'clock podcast or go to our blog
which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you would
like to support the show that way and
remember to check out our regular
episodes which come out every Tuesday
and I think that'll do it for this
episode
yes yeah don't do it alright see you
next time bye